here it goes I'm getting it ready for
you that's my baby's food and I'm gonna
give it to people who are probably gonna
say like oh this is gross
I'm kind of hoping that it tastes like
unsweetened vanilla Trader Joe's milk
I'm hoping that it tastes like regular
milk man this is baby juice like this is
supposed to keep little kids alive so I
feel like it's gonna be full of
nutrition I've always wanted to try it I
think it'll be like regular milk but
sort of like the difference between beer
and root beer maybe it'll make us feel
like kids again I don't know why I think
it's going to be really gross oh my god
this is too real I can't smell a thing
maybe talk sounds like milk Oh does it
smell sour to you I don't know mm-hmm
it's a nice Pig shell green for Mother's
oh hi okay you know it's like pretty
good oh my god it's actually really good
there's like a kind of aftertaste that
tastes like a baby smells though after
I'm finished making this the only thing
I'm gonna need is there someone to pat
my back so that I can burp
so we'd like to introduce you to someone
who that's your good eye your milk yeah
where your baby just came out of a woman
yeah